[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
guys way back in 2008 the smash bros
melee scene gave us esports gold when
they popularized the term wombocombo
now of course since then it's moved on
to a ton of different games and we
thought it was about time we highlighted
the best wombo combo ever from League of
Legends and dota 2 to overwatch and
right back to smash bros oh sorry you're
not clear on what a wombo combo is
exactly well the score boards daniel
rossen defines wombo combo as when two
or more players on the same team
combined their attacks and abilities in
a damaging and flashy combo that usually
results in a dead enemy alright now that
that's out of the way let's kick things
off with some og wombo combo from smash
bros
oh yeah this is a real uphill battle oh
my god no way
no way okay he's trying to get in there
get some Wi-Fi goodness oh that's they
have another one like that begins you
look at you see Texan I like he's like
knows how hard you just got rekt and now
we got a to be 100 system on blacks the
cuffs black and take out Tojo quick or
[ __ ] you taking all the up smashes all
team combo wombo combo oh oh oh my moon
they slip you have that esteem for time
goopy you definitely like makes him oh
whoa my god this is anyone's game right
now yeah right now the big scary target
is going to be Android but armadas
almost at ko / Central Park's up smash
as well who's gonna die first
let's barely miss the Sheik back here oh
hell oh my goodness
okay I'd like to save attempt if he gets
that shine that gives us another
opportunity jail might fall out and I
don't think about polite with your food
yeah it's like they're all out of fest
right now it's like all right guys let's
just uh play random characters and just
yes but my team is bringing it back
right now red team was bring it back
right there red team
destruction is he gonna rest oh my god
are you serious Wow are you serious are
you what
[Music]
alright guys so yeah we're here revival
of melee six alright guys I'm not gonna
lie those wombo combo were so sick they
made me want to pop off but stay in your
seat
put down the GameCube controller and
pick up your mouse and keyboard just
here are some of the best wombo combo
from league of legends boy buddies to
make his team fight impact belt if they
want to make that part more it's so
scary watching them try to get away they
keep punching up so much of Saint
[ __ ] get it with the black dog by
Gossard wombo combo there's nothing else
to say about it
velocity gets destroyed a positive spin
on it and say look we thought that they
were just unstoppable but now and I said
you get really man lockup into a three
man let's backs into a three man laughs
breath and that is exactly what this
composition was to save me the great
found it got you already bang it's
hiding he's coming
your shock wave and SKT with a filter
response will take down
and now most of the leaders are coming
towards the mid lane that's the fly over
the giant knock I'm gonna find three
with the offices down one four zero
third shot for the Train only on the
supporters M not going to make it much
longer as well the chase is it look at
this beautiful plays out of Baker the
intricate beautiful craters were both
fired actually started Dignitas cutting
a big run of this play covers it up to
the strip of bones and dig was a slick
one what fight is all it took for the
Twitter
[Applause]
[Applause]
they gonna pull on Sammy's dad on 20
pounds extended it is very very bright
it's gonna be our annoying that's gonna
pay for it with his life he goes now
that's gonna be old when it's a great
open a vegan pizza that was a full four
three two alternate maker has been out
of position because all right also have
position we hear an ultimate pop turn
your shall we showers as you were saying
that's his focus without any magic
resistance that's gonna be the gnar
ultimate into the tidal wave turn wait
for the beautiful ultimate where is this
shock wave it's only one five seconds
arid and the farm Anwar Cabo that's
they were looking for all cave that may
seal the deal they're still losing a lot
of HP but it was all the control that
they needed trying to get the beacon see
mom is pretty low palm eating a bunch of
damage
smeb though waiting in the wings to get
this big knock if he's gonna find them
the heroic entrance Akbar a huge [ __ ]
effectively engage that Casey was
looking for and this time ever it will
have zero chance of winning this fight
the invisibility that which will allow
multiple duskblade Prague's if you can
get it the shock wave was great but even
a S sub Dornier I don't go far you
really style event it's butter city but
provide aa probative mass the first book
that could contain short for simple
sugars as simple to enjoy that bar for
Arthur Lucas Tata put a cube about this
to get post about Minerva
they're trying to force fights he does
get it know if adidas Jean Pigozzi
funfetti and Mac huge routine as well
bet Kobo and in an apex they find the
miracle teamfight a boy zero in in Maine
Justin II no fee no winner garbage
Topolsky way
[Applause]
Mitsy go to flash WL believe and he did
these safe until after when he'd already
been poked out solo that was a mistake
for him diamond though he's gonna go
anybody's gonna get down here boy also
it will be go speculative get you to use
our t goes who actually popping his own
ulti walk oh my god count the salty
backed it with it
Wow well that was just the first entry
in this video from the MOBA crowd and I
gotta say the league WOM bows were
pretty impressive now let's see what
dota 2 has to offer no one really close
but not close enough to break the
Smokies under the cover of an industry
going really into the middle kershaun
they'll walk out the fine runs away the
greatest play ever only failed to win
the teamfight
Randy has the high ground position with
the meta moment he's focusing something
it's almost a third way to live through
this one now you'll set the fight time
it's great presidents rub the hex over
the mandala still inside the pen VP
applause turn and now they can re-engage
LGD they flip it like a pancake
[Applause]
Peltier bullet from the rail faint just
crapped on photos bro in front of
birdshot trend [ __ ] shoot me tries to
get the cowgirl freaking just get it out
and the fail would stop so what I would
you stop it what can we get her ion we
could get a replay that he is just
evaporated the decade our lives are
doing it take over the throne it could
be game phonics down alliance julius
vici gaming start to outplay vp down the
stretch here and now they've got them on
the run they damaged no one they chased
forward party gays there but now
door slams shut and cuts them off at the
ends sighs in the back they watch the
cheer three tower Falls I channels they
missed anything this is entrant is a
five year old back wall epicenter on top
they kill to make it three straight away
this is the turn for optic they have not
lost it yet the dark seer low three
survives only because of the Aeons is
but they get obliterated he can chase
forward speed breakers gonna go down OS
4 he's thinking about it oh he wants it
so for Blackpool on the floor that
caught a wall this Sunday on topic for
therefore the break that one the
supernova follow-up everybody's gone
triple kill who for sumail easy-peasy as
they all go down GG man would frickin
exclamation mark that's how you end a
game of dota 2 right there this is this
is really good seein how burning get a
lot of farm in the jungle he's not going
to be as scary
bottom lanes gonna run into a lot of
heroes you don't want to commit so many
on to the banner but if you can't get
any abilities up they might get up
though they play they get the fire
killed also it troubles all of bgj storm
fall our flies hit silo full five
seconds they waited out the Naga
illusions hovering around and now as
ceases well thank you very much all it
takes one of those two myself as a
souvenir horn MSS considering the forest
rank poll but they all get fatally
wounded they had to bow even the old
chicken who was also left by the fatal
boss and he heard together they intended
for the clips back in fake Organa
Table five the kill Hebert get T's wine
and that is the epitome of a disaster I
don't think did you're interested in
confessing this horn fire but maybe they
could can lay it long enough at Cydia
five on fighters they ice blast and
Fisher properly there is no hook shot
they're all together
PPG he comes the ice blasts or any
[Applause]
well that's it when it comes to the main
esports MOBAs for wombocombo z'
rest in peace heroes of the storm so now
it's time for wombo combo from the first
and only fps to be in this video
overwatch ripped I also have an
orthodontist explosive potential is
there in spades to say the very least
thought about getting my grants party to
really catch the valiant off-guard
it thinks twice about it there's gonna
be the grand and connects with four
player
oh the good stuff you see from kireev
the book with the fusions doing villa
they've had two successful grab
coalescence combos they also have a
self-destruct they also have a shatter
there just thank-you notes for the big
team wife but here we go that's all
about that CC graviton surge comes in
from valiant figure be patient earth
shadow comes through as well
the combo from Philadelphia fusion there
about one quite away from taking Oasis
here still have transcendence Mirage and
self-destruct they got everything online
really at this point he's just wondering
when are these guys gonna push through
the door so I can just plummet down from
the sky
that was sick control oil point is a
problem for San Francisco time who tried
to be cute and like turn around to get
that hook when Dante was expecting that
he was ready nice and early concert but
the pulse bomb goes in it's a big bang
and Dante it's laundry and the D back
out of that I haven't seen that without
a while it's at Dante who's actually
behind enemy lines translocator
this could hurt now he'd like to join up
something gentlemen spent by the way
your foreplay song my attacks would have
run away now and there's time you can
follow this up with me and feed up a lot
of people hacked up by people hacked
Lucy a very good transcendence here from
Hager puman it might not even be enough
despite that with a barrage especially
if it's damaged booster that's also
gonna make life a little bit harder
ok first Randy for proper now the
animals might wanna try and interrupt
this again into the big chase up a
couple more close and thought about the
resurrect a fire alive it's gonna be a
five already making its way out on the
high ground carpet getting very close to
that crab we will have the barrage combo
letter right now gone for the dead I
just create some space here to get a few
extra meters on this payload as they
push board for the second point trance
has been used now it's good set it up
and quad kill break you all think maybe
they were gonna try to push off the top
but no push really happened if it does
get the pick out the shad so the res
might come in yup big goose brings them
back up
our Center comes through both the tanks
knock down that's a triple kill with the
fire strike from Fischer a few moments
later Florida coming back they've got a
lot of Ultimates though this is kind of
what they wanted drop the ultimate some
gladiators now they capitalize with a
combo of their own that's a quad kill
with the dragon strike it just kills
everybody that's a fortune Vic so back
to fact massive combo plays alright guys
so that's all we got for the best wombo
combo across mostly every eSport now if
you do want to see more videos just like
this one you already know what to do
hit the youtube wombo combo that means
liking the video subbing to the channel
and showing us some love in the comments
below see you next week thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]